This is a download from BBC Learning English. To find out more, visit our website.
Hello, this is 6 minutes English from BBC Learning English. I'm Sam.
And I'm Neil.
Woo! Trick or treat.
For listeners at home, Neil is dressed up as a ghost. He's wearing a white bedsheet over his head
with two holes, cussed out for his eyes, which must mean...
It's Halloween! The start of autumn, when the days get shorter and leaves fall from the trees,
marks Halloween, a festival which is celebrated all over the world at this time of year.
In Britain, people carve scary faces into pumpkins and children go trick or treating,
dressing up in fancy dress costumes and visiting people's homes, shouting,
trick or treat for sweets and candy. Halloween comes from an ancient festival called
Sauwen, which celebrated the changing of the seasons, a time when it was believed the dead
could make contact with the living, which is why children dress up as ghosts,
which is an other scary monsters. But recently, online shops have removed
several Halloween costumes, including creepy clown masks and real-life serial killer costumes.
After parents complained, they were too frightening. In this programme, we'll be discussing whether
Halloween is no longer harmless fun, and as usual, we'll be learning some new vocabulary as well.
But before that, and since you're all dressed up as a ghost, Neil, my question is this,
why did people traditionally dress up in costumes on Halloween? Was it A, to scare their
neighbours as a joke? B, to use up their old clothes or C to hide from ghosts?
Hmm, I think it was to hide from ghosts.
Okay, Neil, we'll find out the answer later in the programme. In recent years, Halloween has become
more influenced by American horror movies like Friday the 13th or Scream. Some parents now think
Halloween costumes are too scary and over the top, a phrase meaning too extreme and unsuitable.
Mother of two, Joanna Connell, was shocked when she took her 10-year-old dorsus shopping for
Halloween costumes. Here she explains what she saw to BBC Radio 4 programme, You and Yours.
They've seen decorations of small children holding a teddy bear covered in blood. They've seen
what's described as a standing animated decoration, which looks like a dead girl carrying a knife.
And various grim reapers, creepy clowns and stuff that kids are now finding, frightening and even
to turn a head off they look pretty vial actually. And I think it feels like retailers, it's a some kind
of race to the bottom for the grimest most vial sickening outfit so that they can just make money out of.
Joanna was horrified by Halloween costumes of the grim reaper, an imaginary skeleton who wears a
long black cloak, carries a sharp cutting tool and represents death. She's worried that costumes
like this are too frightening for little children. Nowadays, Halloween is big business and Joanna
thinks that the focus on money encourages shops in a race to the bottom, a phrase which describes a
situation where companies compete with each other to sell as many products as cheaply as possible.
The phrase is connected to the idea of standards getting worse and worse.
But come on, Sam. Isn't this going too far? I mean, Halloween is supposed to be scary.
Yeah, parents don't want to stop people having fun, but over the top costumes are too scary for younger
children. And some mums say they will no longer open the door to trick or treat us because the
costumes are giving children nightmares. Shavorn Freigard, founder of the Parenting website channel Mum,
thinks a compromise is needed. Here she is, talking to BBC Radio 4's, you and yours.
There's a sort of a halfway house, isn't there? I mean, I know everyone refers to the new
generation. There's a snowflake generation and we shouldn't be so worried about our little
darlings, but there's a point beyond which it becomes tasteful or appropriate.
Shavorn thinks that scary costumes are okay for teenagers, but she also wants to protect younger
children. She thinks we need to find a halfway house, a compromise or arrangement which includes
features of two opposing ideas. She also uses the expression, the snowflake generation, a phrase
which is sometimes used to describe the generation of young people who became adults in or after
the 2010s and who are considered by some to be easily upset and offended. Now I can see how some
costumes are over the top and I don't want to spoil Halloween for anyone, so I'll stick with my
bed sheet ghost. Anyway, isn't it time for you to reveal the answer to your question, Sam?
Yes, I asked why people started dressing up at Halloween in the first place and you said it was
to hide from ghosts, which was the correct answer. Hundreds of years ago, people thought that ghosts
would try to return to their old homes at Halloween. People wore masks so that the ghosts would
mistake them for other spirits. Okay, let's recap the vocabulary we've learned starting with
trick-or-treating, the Halloween tradition of dressing up in creepy costumes and knocking on
neighbor's doors, shouting, trick-or-treat for sweets and candy. Over the top, describe something
which is too extreme, unsuitable or unacceptable. The grim reaper is an imagined representation of
debt and looks like a skeleton in a long black cloak. A race to the bottom happens when companies
compete with each other in order to sell as many products as cheaply as possible. A halfway
house is a compromise which includes features of two contrasting ideas. And finally, the Snowflake
generation is used by some people to refer to the present generation of young people who they
think lack resilience and are easily upset. Enjoy Halloween and don't get too scared. Bye for now. Bye.